en plus des fournitures les vêtements
font partie des achats incontournables
de la rentrée et à chaque décennie sa
tendance
florilège pour les écoliers de france
la rentrée a ramené cependant des
plaisir qu'on éprouve qu'à cet âge dans
les années 50-60 le tablier appelée
aussi la blouse était de rigueur
en plus de son côté pratique il
permettait de gommer toutes différences
sociales entre les élèves et il y avait
l'embarras du choix
quel tablier choisir maintenant celui
qui fait fureur et noir vous le savez
comme celui de nos pères mais égayer
d'impy soufflé d'un col corolle rose
bowl buvard encore des carreaux rose et
blanc mais beaucoup de quadriller blanc
ou rouge sur fond noir dans les années
70 le tablier est dépassé dans l'ère des
seventies place à la couleur et au
blouson en cuir
toujours aussi coloré les années 80
souffler un vent de liberté dans la cour
de récré et à la rentrée chaque imposer
son style rétro fifties les années 50 il
ya plein de livres partout j'ai décidé
donc d'être petite fille modèle
donc je suis arrivé en petite fille
modèle mais dommage arriverait avec les
couverts à cette époque le jean était
sans nul doute le vêtement indispensable
pour se faire remarquer l'incontournable
pour être cool quand tu joues tu peux tu
habillé comme tu veux quoi par exemple
que tu vas dans un bureau ta cravate et
tout intellectuel et quand tu vas en
boum j'ai pas gros pull avec le jean
disque ou quoi dans les années 90 la
mode hip hop s'imposer en france et
aussi dans les cours de récré du succès
avec ça on a connu et pour être dans le
coup les baskets était de rigueur pour
la frime pour le sport chaque écolier
avait sa perte pour la rentrée attention
les voilà elles envahissent le
territoire française ou surtout
américaines elles sont omniprésentes
dans les écoles les stades où les rues
ce sont les baskets
on estime à un million et demi le nombre
de ces chaussures qui seront vendues
cette année à la rentrée le double de
l'an dernier dans les années 2000 le
tablier faisait son retour
principalement dans les écoles privées
même si ce vêtement a beaucoup évolué
quatre questions de jouer la séduction
un modèle pour les garçons un autre pour
les filles le nom de l'enfant comme seul
tuerie tueur et des poignées élastique
tablier blouson en cuir ou jean
finalement quel que soit le style
l'important c'est surtout de faire la
différence à la rentrée
[Musique]